断と実行の経営これはやっぱりささん
すごいなと思いますだ人間ついうのは
怠け者なんだって言われたんですよあの元
が動物だからそういう本能を持ってると
あの短期的な痛みからもう逃げ回るしあの
まもう短期的な快楽に飛びついちゃう
だろうはいはいでこれがダメなんだとうん
この動物の本能的なそのうんまあの生心
これをね理性の力でねじ伏せたらうん2つ
の戦選択肢でねどっちがいいかなって真剣
に考えてるんですなんてやつは
YouTubeを見てくださって皆さんえ
こんにちはえ今日はですねすごいですよ
もうスーツでねもう
山登りそしてスーツでもうまさに海の中
みたいなですねもうすごいえチャレンジを
している日本一のえスーツのサダ社長をえ
今回このYouTubeに向かいました
え借金25億円をですねその会社を
引き継いで見事9年連続増収を達成して
ですね今今期42億円というですね売上を
このオーダースーツのサとして今日本一に
なったサさんのですね系鉄学をえここで
ですね今日はご紹介できますよろしくお
願いしますはいえ株式会社オーダースーツ
サのあの代表の佐田と申します弊社は国内
工場は今宮城県の大崎市にありますえ
120人ぐらいの工場ですねからあの中国
にはあの下北省に今350人ぐらいの工場
をえ持っておりましてえそこで作ったあの
フルオーダースーツをえ今国内え46店舗
でえ販売をしていますまお試し1万9
1800円からというま正直この業界では
あの破格と言われる値段設定でえフル
オーダースーツををえ販売しそしてあの
日本人のねえま日本のビジネスパーソンの
スーツ型をとにかくかっこよくしていき
たいというまこんな思いでえ経営をさせて
いただいておりますま社会貢献としては今
スポーツチームさんにえ結構ス政教増えて
ましてえJリーグでは今12チームですね
えま選手監督が恐いてきてもらうスーツ
ですけどねを来てまあのメディアに出たり
あの移動してくれたりしてますま野球は
阪神タイガさんと千葉ロテマリンさんから
Bリーグも今5チームにからま元ナシ
リーグですね女子サッカーのWリーグでは
今3チームにまスツ提供をさせていただい
ておりますいやささんありがとうござい
ますもうねお忙しい中今日時間調整してね
えこの中対談楽しみにしてまし
た私が出会った時ってすっごい苦しかった
時でしょうそうですねあのなんとかそのま
あの赤字続きだったんで黒字しないことに
は何もやりようがないとというなんとか
黒字をしてでも黒字してもく25億借金が
ありましたんでこの借金って減らないん
ですよねうんなるほどあのだ最後結局1億
7000万ぐらい営業利益出したんです
けどま25億有利負債があってあの平均
金利があの4.2%とかあったんで暇で
過重平均とかしちゃったんですよねえ1億
以上金利払ってたわけですよそ1億
7000万出してちょっと減価償却でねま
2億弱ぐらいキャッシュ年間に生み出して
も1億以上金利で払いそして苦しい時期が
なか長い会社って設備投資してませんから
あっちゃこっちゃで機械が壊れたり
パソコン壊れたりするんで修理代だけで
もう残りの1億も全部消えてくんですよ
まし工場持ってる会社ですからはい結構
大きい機械壊れるとすぐ数千万かかるん
ですね店長からあの半分ぐらい最近したら
うんあの金利もね半分で済むようになるし
ちゃんと返せるようになるじゃないですか
と言っていただいてええあのま最近補強し
ていただいたんですねはあで救われたわけ
だで救われたんですが派手な粉食決算をね
繰り返しててですねいろんな妨害の債務
みたいながボコボコ出てくるんですようん
であのま最初優しかったその金融機関の
方々もだんだん怒っちゃってですねもう
最後はもう佐竹はあのどんだけを馬鹿に
するんだみたいな勢でですね怒っちゃって
ま佐はもう自己破産追放とだ会社がだから
収益力あるのは分かったからうんちゃんと
引き継ぎしなさいとうん言ってこの私的
再生が固まって親父の自己破さん準備をし
ながらうんで住みられたい家もだからまあ
できるだけ高く売却をして金融機関の少し
でもその返済に当てるみたいなで住み慣れ
た家出なきゃいけないんだねなんつって
あのがうんだって東京大空後の八原でじい
ちゃんと一緒に家立て直した会社立て直し
た人なんで貴重な人だったんですけどあの
言えてる時だけはねう泣いてたんですよ
もう今でももうあの忘れられないんです
けどでその祖母もだってで家引っ越したら
3ヶ月で新金梗塞で死んじゃってうんそう
なんだでそんなことになるとこ親戚って
いい時は結構仲良くしてくれてたんです
けどその人たちがなんかうんうん私信孝て
けど信孝君はおばあちゃん殺しだみたいな
ねおばあちゃん殺しって言われたりなんか
私が潰したとか言われるとやっぱりねもお
じいちゃんもお父さんも頑張って結構いい
警視だったのに3代目が3代目があの
ボンボンがと悔しいは悲しいわそっから
自分がま引き受けてま覚悟を決めて9年
連続はい増収ととか増収になりましたね
震災が起こってそうだ
うんうんなんか内にヒアリングするとみん
なんかあなたの名前をあげるんでってうん
だってま私20億私的再生で踏み倒してる
んですよこの十字架って金融会じゃ消えな
いっていうのはもうよく分かってたんで
絶対金融機関が許すわけないと思ってたん
ですけどうんうんいいですよって言って
くれてま戻ってこれれてもう1回って
チャンスだからもらえたんですよね私ね
すごいよなあはい腹くってっていうかま
覚悟は違うよねだからね普通の人とは
ね同じだったら安い方がいいに決まってる
わけですよで当時だっったで規制品は全部
メイドインチャイナだったんであのうん
うん関係ないはずだとうんでメイドに
チャイナで安いっつったら若い人は絶対
そっちの方がいいっていうはずなのに
テーラーさんにそれ一生懸命お願うん
メイド2円ってくださいって言といらない
とうちの客は誰もそんなの欲しがらないっ
て言い切るのでうんうんやったら売れます
よっていうのを見せるための氷やったん
ですよ楽天にも店を出して当時楽天に共同
購入っていうのがあったんでなるほどババ
て購入が入ってあの100着まで行ったら
ガンて値段下がりますうんまだバっと入っ
て200着まで行くとま最初設定した金額
の半分ぐらいになるみたいな出し方すると
本当に1回その共同行為のキャンペーン
あると1発200着とかここに入ったん
ですよでそのデータとかねで買ってる人の
値段もってあのあの当時全部楽天さん見せ
てくれたんでえ平均年齢こんなんですよっ
て言うとじゃちょっと使ってみようかな
うちも若いお客さん欲しいしなって言って
やってくれてまガーっと伸びたんですね
新規開拓にそれ使えましたんで震災5帰っ
てきたらや段階世代の方々ってもあの震災
でうん結構皆さん心折れちゃってはいはい
はいもう1回うちと本気で取り組んで若い
人向けのキャンペーンをやってうんうん
売上増やしましょうよって言ってももう
あの皆さんも諦め顔なんですよなるほどな
のでこれはもう今回は製造おろしの方で
震災で失った売上取り戻すのは無理だなと
うんうん思ってまちょぼちょぼやってた
この氷でうんやるとあので色々考えて
ちゃんとやったらできるはずだとうんまあ
車内大反対でええもうあの幹部
あの標を受け取りましてうんええひどい目
に会いました
ねあらゆる逆境には必ずそれと同等かや
それ以上の成功の種が隠されているとま
それをどう受け止めて次のエンジンにする
かさあさん見事にそれをもう本当にくそ
絶対負けないぞというまそういう何くれね
本当にそういう意味では逆境をバネにね
頑張ってま9年本当に増収をしたっていう
のは素晴らしいと思うんですけどでどう
いうタイミングでSNSにこうきっかけ
作ったんですかこれなんか今11万人も
YouTuberYouTubeでしょ
うんなんかYouTubeが銀の盾もらい
ましたでしょ破格の値段でフルオーダー
がって言ってもウブ上で検電したんです
けど嘘つけしか言われなかったんです
ようんんこんな値段のフルオーダーどうせ
来たらあのケとかすぐバリって破れるん
だろうとか言うんで山登っても破れません
とあそこから来たんだ東京マラソン走って
も破れませんとそこでそれをあのやり
ましょうっていうのがまあうちのちょっと
あのとある営業マンからアイデアが出てき
ましてあそうなんだアメリカの成功時で
見せられたんですよこのYouTube
マーケティングだつったらそんな動画見て
の会議だったんで
社長が自社製品で変なことやるとバズ
るっていうこスーツでカグでビシッと決め
て藤登山うんで富士山登ってもうちの
スーツは破れもしないしビクトもしない
いっつってこれですよっていう話になって
ノーと言えずにですねま行ってやってみ
たらまこの動画がま意外なほど好評だった
いやあれ私も見たもんもうはっきり覚えて
ますよ富士登山したってんであの日韓工業
新聞と新聞うんがすぐ主材に来たんですよ
社長特集って変わった社長探してるんです
よね新聞店はいうん出たんで社長この路線
で行きましょうと次は富士山頂から山
スキーて言われたんですよかそれであの
スキーが出てきたんだでゴールデン
ウィークにあの富士山頂から山を滑って
これも結構好評でそうだよね俺も見いまた
取材以来がパラパラ来るわけですようんで
まあのま東京マラソンとかももエントリー
されててでま走ったらままたこれまだ
ゴールで3系新聞さんが駆け寄ってきて
くれてなんでそんな格好そ革靴ですよね
みたいなグだもんだってでまあネタがねこ
定期的に行きましょうて言と1番目に高い
山が富士山でえと2番目は何でしたっけて
と来だけってそれ次行きましょうやって上
から順番にえトップ5を登ってってたん
ですよで5番目が槍ヶなんですねええで槍
に登ってま大体これでね山企画は一通り
やったかなって言ったら5個までせっかく
行ったんだからこれはあのスーツで100
面さ制覇つってギネス取ろうとか言い出す
やつが出て本当に取れるとかわかんない
ですよそ盛り上がっちゃってうん車内の
盛り上がりとかっ大事じゃないですか
やっぱりその覚悟とそれからその実行力ね
決断と実行の経営これはやっぱりささん
すごいなと思いますうんなんかカンブリア
カンブリア宮殿にも出たでしょあそうです
ねだからまあれもあれは本を書いたのが
きっかけであのカブリ屋さんから普通に
あの取材をしたいですっていう話が来
[音楽]
て本のタイトルもすごいもんね迷ったら居
の道を行けだからねこれあのうち田のお
じいちゃんの口癖だったんですよ人間つう
のは怠け者なんだって言われたんです
ようんうんうんあの元が動物だからそう
いう本能を持ってるとあの短期的な痛み
からも逃げ回るしあのまもう短期的な快楽
に飛びついちゃうだろはいはいでこれが
ダメなんだとうんこの動物の本能的なその
まあの生き心これをね理性の力でねじ伏せ
たらうん2つの選選択肢でねどっちがいい
かなって真剣に考えてるんですなんてやつ
はもうねその怠け心ねじ伏せたらもう必ず
どっち行くべきがもう明確だと地名だと
そっち行け
と9年間増収をそして続けて今期42億円
というねまさにそのオーダースーツとして
日本一になったその自分がはい最大自分
自身何を支えにそしてなぜ折れなかったの
かちょっとその辺の話ちょっと聞かして
くれる正直も最初の時はあの本当金融機関
にボコボコにされほ泣きそうでうんうん
うんだ時にあのグラッサ博士の選択理論の
本に出会ったんですようんうんあの本に
書いてあるじゃないですかうんうんどんな
ひどい状況だってうんあのポジティブな
解釈っていうのはうんうん必ず見出せると
うんうんあとはそれをうんあの落しかどう
かだていう風に私はあれを見て読みました
なのでもうどん底でも必死なってその
ポジティブな解釈試練の時じゃないですか
これ乗り越えてとか言ったらもうヒーロー
私がヒーローだって本かけるなぐらいの
もう思いでて思いで食らってたから我慢
できたんですよ逃げることってできたにも
関わら
ずその逃げないでね向かったそして僕は
最近あのFacebook見てると親高校
だよねいっつもこう家族の写真だとかうん
まあね愛犬のね写真とか色々こうはいなん
だろうこうファミリーをすごく大事にし
てるそういう佐田さんってやっぱり僕は
素晴らしいなと思ってんだけどいやあの
ありがとうございますいや本当にあの私が
今こうあるのもうんさっき言いましたけど
やっぱり座右の目にあのソフから言われて
たことんを使ってるようにやっぱり人生の
ロールモデルにやっぱり祖父や騎という
やっぱり自分を育ってくれたあのま親や
あのまぼねあのままオ人生のロールモデル
だぐらいに持っていますのでそ親庫だもん
なその感謝はやっぱりなんとかと思って
あの返せる限りはと思ってで残念ながら先
ま死も死んじゃいましたしあのはだから
この会社に私戻る前に高してしまったんで
本人には解消ないじゃないですかまこれ
大会でよく言われる話なんですけど恩送り
なんて言葉があって先輩から受けた恩は
後輩に返すとうんうんまあの祖父や祖父母
やあまあのま母も早く死んじゃったんで
両親から受けた恩はやっぱり今の家族
そして子供に返さなきゃなと思ってまうん
やってるつもりですまどこまでそれやり
切れてるかわからないですけどねでさき
言ったその逃げないで私いられたのはあの
あの世でじいちゃんが見てるっていうあの
恐怖感があるからですでソフはなんかねお
テント様は見てるおテト様は見てるって
いつも言ってたんですよおテト様まま
天照らすお様美神様ですよねは見てるけど
私にとってはそれより死んだじいちゃんが
見てるの方が怖くてですね戦争帰りの結構
舞踏ですからね
お前あん時逃げたなとうん迷ったら居の道
を行けとおじいちゃんはあれだけ言ったよ
なとお前あの時どっちの道選んだと逃げ
るって道選んだおじちゃんなんて言った
うんであんのよで詰められたら最悪じゃ
ないですかなので私だって怠け者ですし
逃げたいですよでもそれ最後踏ん張れてる
のはもういや絶対じちゃん見てるとってる
からですこんな恐ろしい話じゃないです
からねいやでも本当大したもんだわね今
そしてなんだろううんやっぱりこのコロナ
の後もね必死に頑張って今円安でね大変な
やっぱり厳しい状況だろうけれどもでも
その前に向かう姿勢チャレンジスピリット
こそがま本当に僕は佐田さんをね本当に
あの尊敬します心から
これから自分自身はどういう方向に
向かおうと思ってのこのビジョンを
ちょっと最後にねちょっと語ってそうです
ねこの日本ってスーツ大国だったんですよ
うんあの戦後の方々だってとにかく軍服で
戦地から帰ってきて最初に行くのが
仕立て屋さんだったっていうぐらいだった
んですよねあの上司とかに連れられてそれ
やっぱこれってあのどういう意味合いの
ドレスコードか戦後の方々っって教えられ
てたんですようんなるほどあの明日マッカ
さんにプレゼンに行くチャンスをもらっ
たらお前どうするってこれじいちゃんが
よく言われてたんですけど何来てくって
よくあの戦争帰りの分かってはね言われた
んだよおじいちゃんたちはほどうんえっと
えっとえとって言ってたりなんかどっか
体型の似た親戚からなんかいい着用物借り
てとかうん言ってると大体上司からだから
お前は理由なんだ3流なんだと段取り味
ブってあれだけ言ってるだろうかとうん
準備しておけとうんこれからの戦場が
ビジネスの場だと思うんだったら準備をし
ておけでまあ欧米にはとアメリカの大統領
に退治しても全くする必要のない十分な
その表なしのドレスコードがあると何か
分かるかと俺が来てるこれだよ素晴らしい
ビジネススーツはそうですだ当時だから
分かってこれ1着しか持ってなかったんで
1丁ラって言われてたんですよね1チラの
1着くらい持っとけ今の日本人忘れちゃっ
たと思うんですねなるほどね確かになそれ
でだからなんか作用儀なんだからスーツっ
ぽくありさえすればいいでしょうみたいな
違うんですこれってビジネス場においては
これ最上級のこれ表なしアイテムなんです
よね素晴らしい会う相手にま自分と会う
時間を作ってうんくさってありがとう
ございますという感謝とそしてあなたを
大切に思ってるんでというその経緯をうん
感謝と経緯を会う相手に伝えるための
ドレスコードなんですよだから首脳会談
っていうと各国主は必ずこれ来てるじゃ
ないですかうんうんG7だG20だって
首脳会議つったらこれ来てるわけです
ようんまその退治する相手のその首脳に
対してもしくはその首が背負ってる国に
対して例を尽くすためにこれを着てるわけ
じゃないですかそうですでこのことをなん
かねもう日本人一時はお客様は神様ですと
社内顧客も神様ですじゃ誰に会う時もこれ
着なきゃだめですよねつってもう誰も彼も
がどんなシーンですらこれ着なきゃみたい
になっちゃったせいでなんでこれ着なきゃ
ダメなんでしたっけって逆に忘れちゃった
んですよ日本人っでうんなるほどそれが
ちょっとコロナでひどくなっちゃったうん
このことを改めて日本人に思い出して
もらおうと思ってますななるほどこの
ドレスコードの持つ意味をそうすればもう
日本人あの表なしの頃に関しては世界地だ
と思ってるんでなるほど世界のビジネス界
における日本人のステータスだって上がる
と思ってますんでなるほどうんまこれが
うちの会社がやるべきことなのかなという
風に思ってます本当に不屈の
精神そして親
高校自分自身の今まで受けてきたことへの
オオ送りまこういう素晴らしい企業家
スピリットと本当に経営者としての本当に
能力を有してる素晴らしい人物だと思い
ますこれからもねござぜひ頑張って
くださいあの是非皆さんあの佐田さんの
ジャンプ台を飛ぶ姿youtubeで確認
してくださいどうも今日ありがとうござい
ましたいやこちらこそありがとうござまし
たどう
もありがとうございました
壮絶ない想像できないですもんね25億の
状態なんてねいやあいやだから本当に常人
じゃはないよ本当にこれ2003年に
お父さんから戻ってきてって言われた時は
破綻寸前だということは知ってたんですか
えっとあの厳しい状況だってのは分かって
ましたけどここまでとは全然知らされずに
で帰ってみたらいきなりあの挨拶周りが
あるから実員持ってこいって言われて
何か分からずに行くと書類がぶわっで金感
もあるわけですよぶわ出てきて私ここにお
名前と実よと言われて先にだから状況把握
する前に連帯保証人にされましたすいで後
でま色々勉強しとけつってもらった資料見
たらまこの状態だったわけですよ何この
借金売上超えてんじゃんで暇なんでね過重
平均とかてやってみたら金利4.2%
つまり1億払
3期連続8000万以上の営業赤だし3期
連続キャッシュ0だし08000万赤掘っ
て一億金利払ってなんで翌年0に戻るのか
聞きに行ってもちゃんと教えてくれないん
ででで喧嘩してたんですよそういうことだ
よねそれ外的コントロールでそうなるよね
あま親父にも外的コントロールで向い親父
元々超外的な人だったんでとか親父も大会
ですからあそれでいいのかお前はみたいの
が愛さえあればそれがあの泣いてき
コントロールだと思ってましたから私も
そういうコントロール受けてたんででも
怒られてても結構愛は感じていたのでそれ
でのかお前とか言って言われるのそのまま
社員にやってたらついたあだ名がサダム
だっ
た本当にもう何を勘違いしてたんですかね
本当にねでもね愛される傾斜になったから
ね良かったねこのああの頂点の道を
ちゃんと7回受けてですねあのあの家庭で
あ俺勘違いしてたんだって理解できたんで
正直今があると思ってますねはいこれから
も応援します頑張ってさどありがとう
ございましたありがとうございます本当に
ありがとうございますありござどうどうも